parlons d'europe avec la maison de
l'europe des yvelines sur sensations
avec le soutien financier de l'union
européenne
bonjour motif bonjour ça va bonjour à
toutes et à tous et bienvenue dans
parlons d'europe
une émission qui s'inscrit dans le cadre
de la conférence sur l'avenir de
l'europe et de la grande consultation
citoyenne qui est actuellement en cours
et vous êtes d'ailleurs invité à donner
votre avis à partager vos idées sur la
plateforme numérique futur eu une pointe
europa point thème de ce numéro les
droits des femmes dont l'union
européenne
mathis oui sarah la finlande a par
exemple été le premier pays européen à
reconnaître le droit de vote des femmes
c'était en 1906 en france il mieux en
mieux leur sera accordée qu'en 1944
politique éducation emploi santé dans de
nombreux domaines et des inégalités
entre les femmes et les hommes perdure
même si on va le voir il y a des eaux
amélioration et que l'on peut même si
s'inspirer de certaines initiatives chez
certains de nos voisins
cette émission se veut interactive elle
a été préparée à travers un atelier
radio par des collégiens des lycéens des
étudiants des jeunes qui sont aussi
allés à votre rencontre vous le verrez
nos invités répondront aux questions que
vous vous posez
et puis nous relèverons aussi les
questions que vous nous avez posé sur
les réseaux sociaux
parlons d'europe
nos invités justement dans un instant et
venir au clair les députés autrichiens
et présidente de la commission des
droits des femmes et de l'égalité des
genres
irène tolérait les re députée française
et membre suppléante de la commission
des droits des femmes et de l'égalité
des genres et pour commencer nous
recevons olivier jeunes ex responsable
des routes directes saint germain en
laye bonjour olivier jonah hex et je
vous propose olivier jonah hex d'écouter
ce micro-trottoir thomas de
l'association hf prévention est allé
faire le point avec vous sur les droits
des femmes et leur avance et on en parle
tout de suite après alors saviez vous
quelles sont les avancées pour les
femmes en
en europe non je crois pas vous répondre
franchement là non je fais avancer des
femmes il ya eu le droit de vote à
l'époque le droit de vote way en 45e
liv et j'ai aussi
en 1973 la loi pour les vg je sais que
il ya longtemps on y avait le droit des
votes mais maintenant maintenant il ya
des femmes au pouvoir je tire il y en a
eu au ministre après je sais pas je sais
pas honnêtement je n'ai pas tellement de
10 des là dessus si je pense que les
femmes osent maintenant beaucoup plus
d'avancé et que je parle par le temps
c'est en arabie cod tous élèves c'était
autre chose
ouais non mais on en europe je pense que
maintenant la femme est un peu et qui va
alors peut-être pas au niveau salaire le
droit de vote le droit de vote le droit
de vote
le droit à une certaine indépendance par
rapport à
à son conjoint à son mari le droit même
de d'avoir un compte
un compte bancaire à son nom sans
demander l'autorisation à son mari assis
lui louera des votes les droits des
appartements de diviser les femmes
parlent plus
avec tout ce qui est dans ce ton port
etc
tous et toutes ces situations qui la
parole se libère mais olivier jeunes
mecs on va s'intéresser à quelques
traités par exemple le traité de rome de
1957 fait de l'égalité entre les femmes
et les hommes
une valeur fondamentale de l'union
européenne de quoi s'agit-il
alors le traité de rome dans son article
119 prévoit chaque état membre assure au
cours de la première étape et maintien
par la suite l'application du principe
de l'égalité des rémunérations entre les
travailleurs masculins et travailleurs
féminins pour un même travail
alors c'est actuellement devenu
l'article 151 du traité sur le
fonctionnement de l'union européenne
concrètement ce que ça veut dire ça veut
dire que l'union européenne a intégré
dès le départ le principe de l'égalité
alors à la base de l'égalité de
rémunérations hommes femmes directement
dans les traités pour vous donner un
équivalent c'est comme c'est comme faire
en sorte que l'égalité hommes femmes
soit inscrit dans la constitution
française
donc ça veut dire que l'on va donner à
ce principe une force juridique très
importante et vu qu'elle va avoir la
force d'un traité les citoyens les
citoyens les hommes les femmes quand il
quand ils travaillent dans leurs
relations de travail si à un moment il
s'estime victime d'une discrimination
sur la base de la caisse sur la
concernant la question de la
rémunération ils ont la possibilité
d'aller agir en justice est de pouvoir
utiliser justement ce fondement
juridique des traités européens
donc de cet article 151 tf yeux pour
pouvoir obtenir réparation et
cette voie là c'est véritablement un
article qui est véritablement un article
qui est très important parce que quand
on regarde si on repositionne un peu ce
que par rapport à l'époque on sortait de
la sorte et de la seconde guerre
mondiale et on avait eu un ensemble de
textes qui entre guillemets pousser les
états à agir sur la question de
l'égalité hommes femmes notamment au
niveau de la rémunération et pendant
très longtemps en fait on donnait pour
schématiser on donnait une simple
obligation aux états d'essayer un peu
d'avancé en la matière et l' avantage au
niveau de ceux de ce l'avantagé au
niveau des traités européens
c'est que cet article dès 1975 et 1976
en fête a été appliquée a été appliquée
en justice notamment au niveau de la
cour de justice des communautés
européennes et de son arrêt de fresnes
et à partir de ce moment là en fait on a
eu un changement de paradigme où on est
passé en fait d'une on est passé en fait
d'une application qui était beaucoup
plus incitative à une application qui
était beaucoup plus coercitives dans le
sens que des citoyens et dans le cadre
de l'arrêt de friends était une
citoyenne qui n'a vraiment pas hésité à
faire valoir ses droits en justice
oui c'est souvent ne travaillent que les
inégalités sont les plus flagrantes
effectivement aujourd'hui encore d'après
les ong oxfam les hommes détiennent 50%
de richesse de plus que les femmes c'est
énorme
je vous propose d'écouter mature sonne
élèves du collège blaise pascal de
plaisir près de 70% des adultes parce
qu'il n'existe pas réellement d'écart
entre les salaires des hommes et des
femmes à travail égal et l'ennemi ou les
attribuer à des choix personnels fait
par les femmes une femme gagne 27% de
moins qu'un homme au cours de sa
carrière en france pour un poste de et
des compétences équivalentes les femmes
gagnent en moyenne 9% de moins que les
hommes
d'après une étude de 2020 les femmes
sont proportions plus nombreuses à
occuper un emploi à temps partiel que
les hommes +2 28% des femmes actives en
2019 et des salariés à temps partiel
contre 8,3 pour cent des hommes
s'agissant à l'accès à la formation
professionnelle
il semble plus limité pour les femmes
que pour les hommes un nombre d'enfants
égale l'arrivée des enfants dans un
couple avant semble avoir des
répercussions plus importantes sur la
vie professionnelle des femmes que sur
celle des hommes enfin selon une étude
de l'organisation internationale du
travail 41% des femmes travaillerez dans
les secteurs les plus touchés par la
pandémie ducobu 19 oui olivier chanut x
l'union européenne adoptée dès 1975 sa
première directive européenne contre la
discrimination salariale pouvez vous
nous en dire quelques mots
et où en sommes nous aujourd'hui alors
cette première directive donkey la
directive 75 117 cee en fait est une
directive qui vise à rapprocher les
législations concernant l'application du
principe de l'égalité des rémunérations
entre les hommes et les femmes est en
fait c'est la première directive
européenne qui va préciser
spécifiquement ce qui ce qu'on doit
entendre dans l'anneau en dans la notion
d'égalité des rémunérations et pour
rentrer un tout petit peu dans le dans
le contenu donc cette directive prévoit
tout d'abord en fait l'égalité des
rémunérations entre les hommes et les
femmes
elle ouvre aussi la voie
juridictionnelle pour tout salarié
s'estimant lésés par la non application
de ce principe donc par exemple des
états qu'ils n'avaient pas à l'époque si
par exemple des états n'avait pas prévu
la possibilité d'avoir des recours
devant
les prud'hommes ou devant devant un
tribunal donc ces états ont été obligés
de mettre en place ces voies
juridictionnelle pour que les citoyens
et les citoyennes puissent faire valoir
leurs droits elle interdit cette
directive interdit aussi les
licenciements en réaction des salariés
qui ont déposé plainte parce que ça
c'était une pratique qu'on voyait qu'on
voyait assez souvent à l'époque où en
fait bon le temps de la justice prenons
toujours un certain temps ben on avait
des andes
on avait des salariés qui avaient porté
plainte et en réaction pour les
sanctionner des entreprises qui les
licenciés et donc grâce à cette
directive
cette pratique donc a pu être donc cette
pratique a pu être donc complètement
condamné et enfin cette directive a
aussi obliger les états à modifier leur
législation interne pour éliminer en
fait les différentes discriminations
présente dans les dispositions
législatives nationales que ça soit par
exemple dans leurs différents code du
travail ou au sein des différentes
conventions collectives ou accords de
branche et enfin cette directive elle
prévoit aussi donc des obligations
d'information notamment pour les
salariés afin que tout simplement ils
soient au courant que cette directive et
que cette vie active était en vigueur et
que ça aura créé des droits donc après
cette directive a été modifié plusieurs
fois et complétée et actualisées et
c'est actuellement la directive 2006 54
c'est eux qui reste le texte de base sur
le sujet quand on regarde maintenant
l'actualité de qu'on regarde maintenant
l'actuel de 7
de la directive et de légalité de
l'égalité de traitement entre les hommes
et les femmes au niveau du haut niveau
salarial il ya différents éléments qu'on
peut prendre en compte il ya déjà tout
d'abord la question du salaire avec
question de la rémunération alors
traditionnellement on a l'habitude de
dire que les sommes sont payées 25% de
plus en moyenne que les femmes alors
c'est un chiffre qui est globalement
vrai mais qui a mais qui amène à des
précisions parce que là on va être
obligé je suis désolé on va être obligé
de faire un peu de méthodologie pour que
l'on puisse pour que tout le monde
puisse comprendre de ce dont on parle et
qu'il n'y ait pas de débat stérile par
la suite au niveau européen c'est très
compliqué de calculer les les variations
de salaire entre les hommes et les
femmes parce que tout simplement on n'a
pas la même méthodologie de calcul
donc quand on regarde le dénominateur
compte quand on regarde le dénominateur
commun qu'on a actuellement au niveau
européen c'est assez simple on prend en
fait le salaire moyen global des femmes
et on le compare par rapport au salaire
moyen global des sommes donc ça veut
dire qu'on va prendre tous les salaires
des femmes
on va en faire une moyenne ce qui va
donner un salaire moyen on va calculer
le salaire moyen comme ça des hommes et
on va en faire une moyenne et donc on va
faire le rapport du salaire des femmes
sur le salaire des hommes et donc si on
prend sept
si on prend cette méthodologie
actuellement au niveau de l'union
européenne
alors sur les derniers chiffres qu'on a
de 2019 parce que là avec 2020 et 2021
ça a été ça a été très compliqué avec la
situation sanitaire
actuellement du moins en 2019 les femmes
étaient payées en moyenne 14,1 pour cent
de moins que les hommes au niveau de
l'union européenne
quand on regarde pour la france c'est un
taux qui s'établit à 7 9 % donc on est
un peu au dessus de la moyenne
européenne
quand on regarde qui fait mieux c'est le
luxembourg avec un écart de seulement
1,3 pour cent et le pays qui fait le
pire du moins qui fait le moins bien
actuellement au niveau de l'europe
c'est l'estonie avec une différence de
21 7%
parlons d'europe vos questions la suite
de cette émission parlant d'europe à
présent levin riglaire eurodéputés
autrichienne président de la commission
des droits des femmes et de l'égalité
des genres et irène tolérer eurodéputée
française membre suppléant de la
commission des droits des femmes et de
l'égalité des gens répondent aux
questions que vous vous posez des
questions relayées par raphaël justin
est mature san des élèves du collège
blaise pascal de plaisir dans les
yvelines
comment l'europe at elle déjà fait
avancer le droit des femmes l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes est
inscrite dans les traités depuis 1957
le premier texte un petit peu important
qui parle d'égalité salariale date de
1975 et du fait de ce texte européen
tous les états membres ont dû réviser
leur législation nationale
après l'autre date un peu symbolique
c'est 1979 avec simone veil à première
présidente du parlement européen
depuis trente ans nous avons aussi à un
groupe de travail dédiés à l'égalité au
sein du parlement européen qui s'appelle
la commission femmes et depuis 2010 9
nous avons non seulement une présidente
de la commission donc du gouvernement
d'union qui est une femme madame oursoul
à von der leyen mais surtout nous avons
une ministre donc une commissaire dédiés
à l'égalité
madame helena dalli nous avons donc
plusieurs textes qui ont avancé et qui
ont qui sont aussi sur la table
donc en 2019 un texte sur l'équilibré
vie professionnelle vie privée et sur
l'année 2021 nous avons à travail égal
salaire égal qui est très important
quelles sont les principales avancées en
matière de droits des femmes que
l'europe a connu voilà tout d'abord le
principe de respecter les droits de
femmes c'est vraiment quelque chose à du
dna à de l'union européenne c'est-à-dire
dupuis l'union européenne existe ça
c'est une base de notre part seulement
mentalité ce sont des valeurs et donc on
a fait beaucoup de législation en ce qui
concerne respecter les droits de femmes
par exemple a autrefois
voilà je donne juste un petit exemple a
autrefois c'était normal de dire les
femmes et plus pour une assurance de
maladies privées parce que voilà ce sont
les femmes acquis qui ont des enfants et
donc ça coûte plus d'argent et toutes
sortes de discriminations qui existe
dans la vie quotidienne
on a éliminé c'est à dire le principe de
non-discrimination surtout à au travail
existe il m'a fait beaucoup contre le
harcèlement sexuel
mais bien sûr il ya beaucoup de mesures
qui sont encore à faire pourquoi parce
que il y a beaucoup de deux pays qui
disent ça c'est une question de
subsidiarité il faut faire des mesures
au niveau national et au niveau national
s'est payé ses gouvernants ne fait ne
font pas grand chose donc il reste
énormément beaucoup à faire
quel pays peut on s'inspirer en matière
des droits des femmes voilà imaginer
c'est le nord aux pays scandinaves il ya
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de des
exemples qui sont vraiment super surtout
la ya beaucoup de mesures obligatoires
c'est à dire qu prête ses
responsabilités c'est chouette mais
normalement on a vraiment besoin de
quelque chose qui est obligatoire c'est
à dire les quotas sont très effectif et
pour ça on a beaucoup plus de femmes au
pays nord dans les comités d'entreprise
dans les dents dans les bords qui qui se
sont beaucoup plus de chefs
d'entreprises qui sont des femmes aux
pays nordiques et en plus c'est ce qu'on
a fait aux pays nordiques su ce qu'il
est très important on protège mieux les
femmes contre la violence
nous avons ces tendances la très très
triste que les féministes fémicide
augmente et par exemple en finland il
existe un plan national
des mesures pour regarder su ce qu'on
doit faire pour mieux protéger les
femmes c'est à dire formation pour les
hommes de la police
on l'a augmenté aussi les femmes qui
sont des policiers formation pour les
profs pour les médecins c'est à dire
tout cela c'est absolument nécessaire
mais la france sa séance aussi un pays
que j'admire beaucoup parce que en
france on a fait beaucoup pour augmenter
à les chiffres des femmes qui dirigent
des entreprises aussi et si les quotas
qui sont obligatoires large peut dire
félicitations mais bien sûr il reste
encore aussi beaucoup à faire
le congé maternité est fixé à 10 jours
dans l'union européenne
en quoi est ce une avancée pour les
femmes c'est une avancée majeure sur les
droits des femmes pour deux raisons si
on prend l'égalité salariale on a un
écart de 16 17% entre les salaires des
hommes et les salaires des femmes mais
par contre quand on va au moment des
retraites
eh bien on a cet écart est autour de 38%
pourquoi parce que ce sont les femmes
qui interrompent leur carrière par
rapport à la venue d'un enfant
or notre société a besoin d'avoir des
enfants pour pour tous pour la vie tout
simplement mais aussi pour la vie
sociale et pour la vie économique donc
avoir des dispositifs qui permettent aux
femmes et aux hommes d'être égaux face à
la maternité où la paternité
c'est un pas vers l'égalité qui est
extrêmement important ça permet aussi
non seulement une égalité économique
mais aussi une charge mentale parce que
c'est quand on a eu le confinement
ce sont plutôt des femmes qui se sont
occupés des enfants et il est important
qu'on se dise que ce n'est pas quelque
chose de naturel et que la charge des
enfants
elle est à celui des parents qui à un
moment donné veut s'en occuper et que
cette tâche soit partagé qu'aux portes
et comment l'europe peut-elle inciter
les femmes à se tourner vers certains
métiers où il n'y a que des hommes
alors ça c'est un sujet très important
la face la réponse à votre question
c'est par la formation en faisant
attention à ce que les itinéraires de
formation de métiers dits masculins est
des quotas féminins
pourquoi c'est important d'avoir des
quotas féminins dans les métiers
masculins parce que on peut avoir des
demandes par rapport à la croissance
économique sur certains métiers plus que
d'autres et si ces métiers sont très
masculin on peut avoir
des inégalités qui accompagne le
développement économique je m'explique
crise covin les métiers les plus
précaires sont arrêtés serveuse dans les
restaurants auxiliaires de vie qui
gardait les enfants qui étaient pas à
l'école toutes ces choses là puisque il
y avait plus d'école ça s'arrête et dans
le même temps on sait qu'on va relancer
l'économie autour de métiers du digital
et de l'environnement
ça tombe bien ce sont des filières qui
sont à 70% masculine ça veut dire que si
on n'a pas une action publique
volontaire on va se retrouver à avoir
des femmes qui perdent leur travail et
en contrepartie des métiers plutôt
masculin qui vont embaucher ce chiffre
là c'est de la réalité en décembre 2020
en italie sur un chiffre autour de
116000 destructions d'emplois il y avait
plus de 104 1000 destructions d'emplois
féminine est pareil aux états unis donc
il est très important par rapport au
moment que nous vivons que nous ayons un
regard très précis sur les filières de
formation pour que on sorte de ces
emplois masculins ou féminins et que
tout européen et sa chance face à ce
qu'il veut faire à son talent et aux
opportunités de croissance et de
rémunération qu'offre notre société
comment l'europe lutter contre les
inégalités femmes hommes
il y a beaucoup de mesures 1 nous
attendons encore women who works c'est
une directive de la commission
européenne voilà on a fait un des
piliers des années déjà la de la
position du parlement européen à des
quotas pour augmenter les femmes qui
sont après des romans de l'os vraiment
quelqu'un à admirer de suivre et ça
c'est important
top down et poteaux map est maintenant
très important pour la vie quotidienne
c'est une directive qui s'occupe des
salaires nous observons encore par
exemple chez moi en
autriche à une différence des salaires
hommes-femmes de presque 20 % 20 % et au
niveau européen c'est un peu moi mais
quand même il n'y a pas des raisons
objectif pourquoi des hommes gagner
beaucoup plus des salaires quand ils
travaillent plus ou moins la même chose
que les femmes
donc nous aurons ces directives sur la
table pour prendre mesures pour
améliorer la situation et pour éliminer
les différences
en ce qui concerne les salaires alors
l'union européenne c'est un groupe de 27
pays qui ont décidé à travers des
traités de mettre des choses en commun
ces choses en commun on peut aller
jusqu'à des dispositifs législatifs des
directives donc l'union européenne prend
une directive et les appliquent les
états membres ont l'obligation de
transposer dans l'organisation nationale
ou bien un règlement qui s'applique de
la même façon dans toute l'union
européenne donc ce sont bien des
dispositifs législatifs qui vont venir
dans un premier temps c'est ce dont je
vous ai parlé mais on peut aussi avoir
des dispositifs budgétaires l'union
européenne donne beaucoup d'argent à la
politique agricole commune à la
politique de cohésion
jusqu'à présent on peut pas dire que
l'union européenne ait brillé par une
quelconque attention sur le fait que cet
argent aille plus ou moins à des femmes
ou à des hommes et je crois que c'est
l'étape dans lequel nous sommes
aujourd'hui c'est justement de blindés
que nous allions réellement vers
l'égalité
y at il encore de grandes disparités
entre les femmes et les hommes
commencent explique-t-elle oui il a
encore des grandes disparités entre les
hommes et les femmes
il doit bien y avoir une partie
culturelle puisque quand on voit
certains pays nordiques qui sont
beaucoup plus en avance sur certains
sujets que certains pays
latin maintenant
l'union européenne s'est unie dans la
diversité
ça veut dire que sur tous les sujets sur
lesquels l'union européenne va avancer
on part du principe que chaque état
membre à un point de départ différent et
du coup on va avoir un objectif lointain
qui est commun mais la route pour y
aller elle doit être adaptée au point de
départ et aux moyens du pays
mais par contre on va bien dans la même
direction et main dans la main avec de
la solidarité
comment au sein de ces institutions
l'europe est-elle progresser les droits
des femmes avec des postes clés
attribués à des femmes avec des quotas
oui ça c'est une bonne exemple on voit
la commission c'est femmes hommes
voilà et quand vous regardez c'est juste
un exemple symbolique mais ça ça nous
dit quelque chose sauf à kate
là on a vu il existe encore beaucoup de
a beaucoup de deux des stéréotypes dans
la façon de penser
voilà là c'était un monsieur charles
michel qui a oublié ou qu'elle vous je
ne sais pas qu'est ce qu'il a pensé
qu'il oubliait qu'il est une équipe qui
les intimes avec la présidente de la
commission et donc c'est important
top down et bottom up de améliorer la
situation
si c'est madame fanta line qui est quand
même la présidente de la commission
européenne c'est à dire c'est une fin
avec beaucoup de pouvoir qui est dans
une situation privilégiée
quand c'est elle qui a déjà des
expériences comme ça comment est-ce que
c'est dans la vie à quotidienne des
femmes aujourd'hui
là les harcèlements sexuels mais aussi
le mobbing le bowling il y a beaucoup de
stéréotypes dans la vie quotidienne
qu'on ne nous comprend on observe mais
quand c'était toujours comme ça on
accepte et ça c'est plus acceptable
c'est à dire les salaires la violence le
à toutes sortes harcèlement donc à et
bien sûr aussi la question qui s'occupe
des enfants parce que là on voit aussi
que c'est surtout les femmes qui sont
encore responsables c'est à dire les
hommes partagent
mais c'est en général la responsable et
responsabilités des femmes de voilà de
s'occuper surtout des enfants
voilà vous en savez maintenant un peu
plus sur ce que fait l'europe pour les
droits des femmes
merci encore une fois à justin mature
sané raphaël du collège blaise pascal de
plaisir dans les yvelines d'avoir relayé
les questions que vous nous avez posé
sur les réseaux sociaux
et puis vous le savez une grande
consultation citoyenne est en cours
jusqu'au premier semestre 2022 vous êtes
invités à vous exprimer et à imaginer
l'europe de demain on vous rappelle ô
vous rappelle d'ailleurs l'adresse de la
plateforme numérique future rue prince
europa.eu plateformes mises en place à
l'occasion de la conférence sur l'avenir
de l'europe
vous pouvez ainsi partager vos idées sur
différents thèmes changement climatique
santé justice sociale et emploi
démocraties européennes transformation
numérique etc
merci motif se parlant d'europe c'est
terminé on se retrouve très bientôt
merci à vous d'avoir été avec nous merci
ça va on espère avoir répondu aux
principales questions que vous vous
posez
et n'oubliez pas de vous prolonger le
débat sur nos réseaux sociaux c'était
parlons d'europe sur sensations plus
d'infos sur maison europe 78e